students take to the airwaves to push
Trump on gun control Fergie does the
worst version of the national anthem
ever and I saw Black Panther and I have
thoughts I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro Theo
so many things going on fer gie li CI
OMG WTF was that no one knows we will
play Fergie's worst national anthem of
all time Roseanne bark and finally
emerge with I think after years of being
shuttled off to safe spaces to prevent
her being hit with Rotten Tomatoes
Fergie has now taken over that role
we'll discuss that we will also
obviously get to more serious business
with regard to the Trump Russia probe
we'll get to more serious business with
regard to the to the shooting in
parkland but before we get to any of
those things first we have to say thank
you to our sponsors over at stamps.com
so stamps.com is the easiest way to
access all the amazing services of the
post office so you love what the post
office does for you I mean they provide
you good prices and they make sure that
your mail gets there when it's supposed
to get there but you don't want to go to
them wait in line at the post office
well stamps calm makes you never have to
do that again you create your stamps
calm accounts in minutes online with no
equipment to lease no long-term
commitments you click print mail and you
are done it is convenient it is easy and
it is reliable you have the scale right
there at your desk you can weigh the
mail so you're never paying for too much
postage and then you print out the
stamps right there on a piece of paper
tape them to the to the envelope or
print them directly on the envelope or
onto a sticker and you are ready to go
it brings again all of those amazing
services at the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail and they make
it easy by sending you a digital scale
that automatically calculates exact
postage they'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your knees
so over here at the daily where we use
stamps calm all the time in order to
save time and energy right now you can
enjoy the stamps comm service with a
special offer from us that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale so what you do is you go
to stamps calm there's a microphone at
the top of the homepage and you type in
Shapiro that promo code Shapiro stamps
comm enter Shapiro after you click on
that microphone at the top of the
homepage and you get a four week trial
plus postage and the digital scale just
a pretty generous offer from stamps comm
to get you started you will enjoy it and
it will save you lots of time and it
will save you lots of money as well so
stamps calm again
promo code ship here and let them know
that we say you okay so we begin with
continuing fallout from the situation in
parkland Florida obviously there's a
horrific awful evil event that occurred
last week in parkland and that's what
Tom
the news over the weekend President
Trump is apparently now considering
whether he is going to push some gun
control measures one of the reasons he's
doing that is because the media have
launched an all-out emotional assault on
gun control
here is what CNN Fox News MSNBC been
doing they've been covering all of the
students from Parkland they're high
school students and they're speaking out
about gun control so here are some of
the students announcing national
demonstrations on gun control today I'd
like to announce that we have an event
coming up to have everybody in the
nation talking about what we're talking
about and one of the things we've been
hearing is that it's not the time yet to
talk about gun control and we respect
that we've lost 17 lives and our
community took 17 bullets to the heart
and it's difficult to come back from
that so here's the time that we're going
to talk about gun control March 24th we
have the March for our lives
which you can find at March for our
lives calm and expect to see us a lot
the March for our lives is going to be
in all every major city and we are
organizing it so students everywhere can
beg for our lives because at the end of
the day this isn't about the red and
blue the GOP and the Democrats this is
about adults and kids now Who am I are
you gonna beg for your life back Trump
for your life as though Trump could just
flip a switch and suddenly these
shootings would not happen anymore it's
that there's significant disagreement
about the method that should be used in
order to militate against these
shootings and they're they're
significant and real disagreements on
this right I've suggested there ought to
be wildly up security standards at all
of these schools there ought to be armed
guards at virtually every door that you
might consider at some of these schools
actually putting into place some some
doors that that can actually close
across the campus and lock like they
have in hospitals in many hospitals they
have lockdown procedures where somebody
in active shooters in the hospital and
so you actually lock off certain parts
of the hospital from other parts of the
hospital so that the shooter can't just
walk through the halls with impunity and
there's a lot of disagreement about this
Democrats won of course bans on all
sorts of weapons including the ar-15
which is the most popular rifle in the
United States but this idea that it's
all about begging that it's all about if
we just cared enough that all of this
would be be fine we just agree on
everything that of course is not true in
the slightest this of course however is
what what the left is suggesting so the
same student Cameron kasky he says
you're either with us or against us
which is pretty wild language
we are all with you no one wants to see
kids get shot you're either with us or
against us we are losing our lives while
the adults are playing around and we
have received endless support from your
generation and we thank everybody for
that immensely because we really
appreciate it we don't need you on March
24th you are going to be seeing students
in every single major city marching and
we have our lives on the line here and
at the end of the day that is going to
be what's bringing us to victory and to
making some sort of right out of this
tragedy I mean what what does victory
look like what does victory look like
that's the real big question okay if
victory is no more shootings than we all
agree on the definition of victory if
victory is a piece of gun control
legislation that may or may not actually
help then we don't agree on what victory
for the country looks like and you can
see that some of these students
obviously they're very politically
motivated that's okay I mean they're
allowed to have their political
motivations my problem here is the same
problem that I have with the country as
a whole the country as a whole takes
being on camera as some sort of
imprimatur of of knowledge some sort of
improvement or of expertise and that's
really silly
so LeBron James speaks about politics
that's his right he's allowed to do it
some of the stuff he says I think is not
completely wrong but why would we treat
as a country his version of politics
with more credibility than people who
have studied the issues and studied the
personalities for a long time I don't
and I don't think other people should
why would we take a bunch of high school
juniors and say that these are experts
on gun policy now they're not experts on
gun policy simply because their school
is targeted these are people who have
experienced significant pain and
obviously we all stand with them in and
more and with them in that pain they
have it to a far greater degree I'm sure
than anybody who's who's far away but
that does not mean that what they are
saying on politics has any more
legitimacy or that it has any more
expertise to back it and yet there's a
reason the media does this right after
after the Boston Marathon attacks
did you see victims of the Boston
Marathon attacks on TV every day
stumping for a travel ban on Muslims of
course he didn't after the Orlando
shootings did you see victims of the
Orlando students who are not left-wing
going around and saying what we need
here is a restriction on the number of
Muslim immigrants from countries we can
vet of course you didn't write the media
go out of their way to put people on
camera who are sympathetic this goes all
the way back to the Sandy Hook shooting
when Piers Morgan was attempting to do
this routine and I and I
called him on and on air it's highly
irritating to me and it's intellectually
dishonest but there's a reason that all
these kids are being put on TV and to
put pressure to the idea by the way that
a child shall lead them when it comes to
politics is silly and then the idea that
the children are our experts on policy
because they have greater innocence no
that means that they don't know enough
there's a reason that you don't let
seventeen year olds to find tax policy
and you shouldn't let seventeen year
olds to find gun policy either depending
on whether they've actually studied the
issue in any significant way but again
the media have a real interest in
trotting out these kids here's another
student talking about how Trump sickens
sickens the student president Trump you
control the House of Representatives you
control the Senate and you control the
exam he doesn't you haven't taken a
single bill for mental health care or
gun control and passed it and that's
pathetic we've seen a government
shutdown we've seen tax reform but
nothing to save our children's lives are
you kidding me you think now is the time
to focus on the past and not the future
to prevent the death of thousands of
other children you sicken me
Trump sickens him okay well again Trump
does not control the house he does not
control the Senate I mean basic civics
education would be useful here these are
independent branches of government and
they have to propose and pass
legislation
Democrats would filibuster presumably a
lot of legislation Republicans would
propose and Republicans are not gonna
propose legislation that their base
doesn't want and that their voters don't
want this is how a republic works again
the reason the media are going back to
the well here is because they're
attempting to create an impetus for
action that there is no political
impetus for right now this is aimed at
the public it's not really aimed at
Trump or even the legislators it's aimed
at the general public the suggestion
being that if you disagree with these
students and if you don't feel their
pain in the same way that they do and by
feel their pain we mean agree with them
then that means that you are obviously
an uncaring individual there's another
student doing this routine yesterday not
because we are going to be another
statistic about mass shootings in
America but because as just as David
said we are going to be the last mass
shooting
okay but here's the reality that's
probably not true and none of the gun
control man I mean it's an unfortunate
reality but none of the gun control
measures that are currently being
proposed by the Democrats would have
stopped what happened in parkland I've
yet to hear a concrete proposal you
heard one I haven't heard any concrete
proposal none right this piece of crap
who shot up the school had smoke
grenades on him we still don't know how
he got the smoke grenades do you think
would have been a bit had been
impossible for him to go through and
shoot all these students with a handgun
that's right that's what the student at
Virginia Tech use used a handgun in that
shooting so blaming me the ar-15 is is
not going to stop these these mass
shootings again all of this is about
generating emotional appeal not about
making a logical appeal but the real
goal here is to is to get politicians in
front of these kids so these people can
great the the politician so Marco Rubio
is falling for this he's gonna go talk
to the victims on camera in front of CNN
it's not our job to tell you senator
Rubio how to protect us the fact that we
even have to do this is appalling our
job is to go to school learn and not
take a bullet you need to figure this
out that's why you were unfortunately
elected your job is to protect us and
our blood is on your hands
okay our blood again our blood is on
your hands I mean only if you think that
the government has gotten can prevent
every single thing or unless you get a
piece of legislation that is backed by
evidence and can suggest that there will
be no more mass shootings if you pass
this piece of legislation and then then
we can actually have a conversation but
here's the truth we know why this
shooting took place we know what failed
here we know what went wrong here and
I'll explain to you in a second what
exactly that was and it was not lack of
gun control I'll explain that in one
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Indo chinos so
there is nothing that makes a guy look
better than wearing a tailored suit
dudes look better in Taylor toot it's
why James Bond is always wearing a
tailored suit it's why you should be
wearing a tailored suit and I don't just
mean something you got off the rack and
then went to the tailor to fix up I mean
something that is made from scratch and
that's where endo Chino comes in they're
the world's largest made-to-measure
menswear company they've been featured
in major publications including GQ
Forbes and fast company they make shoots
suits shirts made your exact
measurements for a great fit guys love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and the option to personalize
all the details including your Ella Pell
lining in monogrammed I have an endowed
Chino suit it is spectacular two
three-piece suit the best and I went in
one of the indogene Oh showrooms and
they asked me all the available changes
that I wanted to make how I wanted the
stitching done it's really really cool
here's how it works you can either visit
a showroom or shop online in Indo Chino
calm you pick your fabric you choose
your customizations you submit your
measurements and then you wait for your
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks and this week my listeners can get
any premium Indo chinos who for just 379
bucks at Indo Chino comm when entering
Shapiro at checkout again that's Indo
Chino calm you answer Shapiro checkout
and the price of that suit drops to
three hundred and seventy nine bucks
that is 50% off the regular price from
made-to-measure
premium suit and shipping is free so
Indo Chino comm promote repeal for any
premium suit just three hundred $79 in
free shipping it's an incredible deal
for a suit that's gonna fit you better
than anything off the rack ever could
they just ask you for your measurements
and they send it directly to you in the
mail and it is the best fit that you
will have in a suit again Indo Chino
calm and use promo code Shapiro check
out a suit made for you and made to
measure pretty fantastic and again
cheaper than a lot of the suits you get
off the rack for just 379 bucks right
now when you enter Shapiro at check out
Indo Chino calm and the answers promo
code Shapiro I check out okay so what
exactly went wrong in parkland we know
what went wrong at Parkland have the
left insists that the government must
have total control over guns in order to
stop mass shootings like what happened
at Parkland but we found out that the
government won't do that okay we found
out the FBI knew full well about the
shooter in the parkland Florida School
massacre and did nothing two times to
first they were informed in September
the YouTube user with the shooters real
name said quote I'm going to be a
professional school shooter I'm not sure
what you need more than that to go and
check it out the FBI didn't mean for it
to the field office didn't bother to
share the information with local
authorities now The Wall Street Journal
reports that in January a caller told
the FBI specifically about the shooters
quote gun ownership desire to kill
people
erratic behavior and disturbing social
media posts as well as the potential of
him conducting a school shooting what
happened nothing it was ignored it was
not even forwarded to the field office
so when we talk about the government is
is big enough to save us the
government's big enough to protect us
there are thousands and thousands of
people in this country right now who
have felons who have guns and the
government knows about them and is doing
nothing there are thousands of people
who are in the mental health roles and
they have guns and the government is
doing nothing about them and you're
telling me that a mass gun confiscation
is the way that you're gonna take care
of this or even forgive him a march in
the street that somehow this is going to
accomplish the end of this one of the
ways that we could actually militate
against this there are two ways that I
would propose
maybe three that would that would
actually mill I can actually name I
think maybe four things that we could do
then militate against all of this so
first thing that we could do is the
media should stop naming shooters and
providing glory to the shooters when we
do this stuff all we ends up doing is
promoting this
these are copycat crimes the huge number
of the school shooters our fans of
Columbine have downloaded information
about Columbine become obsessed with
school shootings and want to imitate it
so you get their name in the papers the
media should have an agreement all the
way through and we're gonna start
implementing this is daily wire now I do
it on my show then we're not going to
name the shooter that is something that
I think everyone should work on in the
media that's something that we can do
first ten second thing we should have
massive security the schools this
idiotic notion that there is a school to
Prison Pipeline is not backed by data
that if you have a bunch of armed guards
in the schools then kids are being
arrested for silly crimes and then being
sent to prison it's just not true the
data do not support that we had a whole
article by Hank Berrien over at the
Daily wire about this you can go and
check that out it is not the case the
other things that we can do the mental
health screenings that are already
taking place there need to be more
transparency all this information needs
to be transmitted to local authorities
it all needs to be put in the databases
people need to be fired or lose their
jobs or lose their careers if they do
not enter information that is relevant
and then something terrible happens
because I promise you for every school
shooting that happens like this were the
FBI missed it there are a hundred other
instances where the FBI missed it but
there was no school shooting if this
happened once this happened a hundred
times we've now had the FBI and the CIA
missed things in the San Bernardino
shooting in the Texas shooting in this
shooting in the Charleston shooting the
government is not doing what they are
already hitting what they already have
the power to do so that's something that
we certainly should be taking a look at
so that those are those are three things
right off the bat that we should be
looking at David French has a proposal
over at National Review that is called
the gun violence restraining order and
what he suggests I want to find the the
actual verbiage so he says that what we
should do here is we should have gr vos
he says there are various versions of
these laws working their way through the
states California passed a gr vo statue
in 2014 and it went into effect in 2016
broadly speaking they permit a spouse
parent sibling a person living with a
troubled individual to petition a court
for an order enabling law enforcement to
temporarily taken individuals gun rights
away a well-crafted GVR ocean
the following elements quote it should
limit those who have standing to seek
the order to a narrowly defined class of
people at close relatives people living
with the respondent and should require
petitioners to come forward with clear
convincing admissible evidence the
respondent is a significant danger to
himself or others it should grant the
response and an opportunity to contest
the claims against him in the event of
an emergency an ex parte order in order
granted before respondent can contest
should be scheduled fairly a full
hearing should be scheduled quickly if
there's an ex parte order and the order
should lapse after a defined period of
time almost petitioners can come forward
with clear and convincing evidence that
it should remain in place so this should
this would be something that we could
all agree on across the board these seem
like reasonable gun control measures to
me and they're not just gun control
measures their societal societal control
measures in the sense that they are
restrictions we place on ourselves in
order to try and tamp down the
possibility of violence here
unfortunately we're not going to have
real conversations about all of this
we're just going to shout at each other
about how we don't care enough and chief
among those people shouting is of course
neil degrasse tyson - neil degrasse
tyson is very angry when people talk
about praying for the victims or praying
for the families of the victims he says
quote evidence collected over many years
obtained from many locations indicates
that the power of prayer is insufficient
to stop bullets from killing
schoolchildren okay evidence gathered
from all over the world from many
locations across thousands of years
indicates that no religious person in
history has ever claimed that prayer
stops people from shooting other people
there's not a religious person in
America who actually believes that if I
pray school shootings will end nobody
thinks that but the left is fully intent
on using school shootings as a club to
wield against their favorite political
enemies a Steven Pinker whose book I'm
going to talk about a little bit in
things I hate I talked about his things
I like last week and then I actually had
a chance to read it and I'm gonna talk
about things I don't like about it but
Steven Pinker is a psychologist over at
Harvard and he was talking about atheism
on MSNBC and suggesting that the that we
should quit it with all of the put it
with all of the religion talk because
obviously God doesn't exist all of which
really cast doubt on the idea that
there's a benevolent Shepherd who looks
out for human welfare I mean what was
the benevolent Shepherd doing in Florida
while that teenager was massacring his
classmates so I don't you know I don't
right in order to win popularity
contests and I say many things some of
which readers will agree with
which they'll disagree with I assume
that readers have enough sophistication
to evaluate different propositions they
may disagree with me on some things and
that that's fine okay so this is the
problem of theodicy okay theodicy is the
problem that has been literally
considered thousands of times by
thousands of different religious
thinkers why would a good God allow bad
things to happen I do love it when
people who are on the Atheist Left
simply declare that the problem of
theodicy is unsolvable and therefore God
doesn't exist as though their mind is
God's mind
bad things happen therefore God doesn't
exist if you're using a school shooting
to make the case against God let me
suggest that your priorities are
misplaced one of the things that can
help here might be a society that takes
virtue more seriously that inculcates
manhood more seriously as opposed to a
society of atomized individuals who
apparently have no responsibility for
one another maybe maybe that's where we
should start when we have these societal
discussions but again it's all taking
advantage Bernie Sanders taking
advantage of the gun control debate in
order to push his agenda even though
Bernie Sanders is voting right on guns
is actually a lot softer than a lot of
other Democrats of course we have to
make it harder for people to be able to
purchase weapons we have people now who
are on a terrorist watch list who can't
purchase a weapon does this make any
sense to anybody bottom line here
Republicans are gonna have to say that
it's more important to protect the
children in this country than to
antagonize the NRA are they prepared to
do that I surely hope they are weird I
can mean cuz Bernie Sanders has said
this quote folks who do not like guns
are fine but we have millions of people
who are gun owners in this country 99.9%
of those people obey the law I want to
see a real serious debate and action on
guns but it's not going to take place if
we simply have extreme positions on both
sides I think I can bring us to the
middle and yet there's no proposal there
there's just casting aspersions at
people with whom he disagrees which is
quite gross again all of this is silly
and you see John Kasich doing the same
thing John Kasich one of the more
gutless politicians in my lifetime the
governor of Ohio who had a pretty
pro-gun record when he was in Congress
and had a pretty pro-gun record as
governor of Ohio now of course he's
coming out and saying we should ban
ar-15s why should we be any ar-15s
what's here's some of the worst logical
running here today from the insufferable
John Kasich he said if all of a sudden
you couldn't buy an ar-15 what would you
lose would you feel as though your
second Amendment rights would be eroded
because you couldn't buy a God darn
ar-15
these are the things that have to be
looked at and action has to happen
before and look you're never gonna fix
all of this but common sense gun laws
make sense okay
common sense will that I've never heard
circular logic like that before common
sense gun laws make sense Thank You
definitionally idiotic human gum the
question is what is a common-sense gun
we'll have an evidence backed gun
proposal how about that same evidence
backed gun proposal make sense not
common sensical most common sense is
very often the last reserve of people
who don't actually want to do the field
work of having to look up the evidence
common sense if they comment when people
say common sense isn't so common that's
because common sense he would actually
involve you looking at the evidence in
the making a policy proposal based on it
by the way the verbiage sure is so
stupid the idea that you know here he is
saying if I can't buy an ar-15 do I feel
like my second amendment gun rights have
been violated
well if I didn't have to listen to John
Kasich when I feel like my First
Amendment rights have been violated
actually yes I don't like John Kasich
but if I couldn't listen to John Kasich
my first amendment rights would be being
violated I have a right to hear what he
has to say what we like and what we
don't is not the measure of a right what
we like and what we don't is a measure
of preference I'm a question of right is
what I have a right to do and what I
have a right to have I don't have to
take advantage of that right in order
for that right to exist I have a right
to sleep with as many people as I want
to in the United States I'm not going to
do that
I don't like me I don't like people who
do do that but I have a right to do that
I have lots of rights in the United
States then I don't take advantage of a
John Kasich apparently thinks that if a
right doesn't of if defeat the
calibration of a reduction of a right
does not affect me then somehow it's not
a reduction of a right that of course is
completely evidence less and foolish but
that's the that's the nature of this
debate evidence listen foolish is I
think what it comes down to in the end
may as we continue here we're gonna talk
about Trump Russia and the Muller Robert
mullet brought down an indictment on
Friday that does some serious damage to
the Democrats claims that he was
colluding with Russia we'll talk about
that in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at my
patreon supply so I saw a report today
and over in Puerto Rico there are now
five months past the hurricane that hit
Puerto Rico and a lot of folks still
don't have food a lot of folks still
don't have water or electricity the fact
is the
can't do what the government says it's
going to do in many cases and that's why
you need a food supply
FEMA has admitted failure and that it is
broke and that it is broken so don't
wait for the next crisis where the
government fails to deliver and grocery
store shelves go empty ensure that your
family is ready use my Patriot supply
they will give you a two-week emergency
food supply to get you started for this
week only these kits are on sale for 67
bucks each which is a saving of $50
two-week emergency food supply for 67
dollars each buy it now your have to
worry about for 25 years because it
lasts for 25 years in storage order a
two week kit for each member of your
family right now eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen or go online
to prepare with been calm it's something
you can get done right now it's very
easy it's very simple and it won't it
won't be a problem
so go to prepare with been calm right
now 888 803 1413 and get your two week
kit from my Patriot supply apparently
it's delicious corn and folks in this
office have tasted they say it tastes
just like home cooking you say fifty
dollars today right now eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
prepare with been calm that's prepared
with been calm one-time expenditure and
you don't have to worry about it for
another quarter century if something
should go wrong if you never use it
count yourself lucky that's a good thing
and so go over my Patriot supply right
now I'm prepared with been calm is
prepared with been calm okay so quick
update on Trump Muller stuff so the
Trump Muller investigation continues to
unspool and it is not providing the sort
of evidence that Democrats who wish that
it would provide on Friday the Muller
investigations grand jury indicted
thirteen Russians associated with
election meddling but that was not the
real headline the real headline is that
among all of this activity nothing all
that serious seems to have occurred I'm
just gonna be frank about this it
doesn't look like any of this weight
anything have him do with the election
none of this looks particularly damaging
and beyond that none of it had to do
with the Trump campaign apparently
knowing about what was going on with
Russia at all
the indictment targets 13 Russian
nationals three Russian entities the
government says we're utilizing quote
information warfare during the election
cycle according to the indictment these
people quote supported the presidential
campaign of then candidate Donald Trump
and worked on disparaging Hillary
Clinton but after Trump's election
according to the same indictment quote
defendants and their co-conspirators
used false us personas to organize and
coordinate other false us personas to or
to organize and coordinate US political
rallies protesting the results of the
2016 presidential election
one of those rallies actually included a
Trump is not my president rally held on
November 12 2016 in other words is the
Russians trying to make trouble during
the election not necessarily backing
Trump per se so what about election
coordination with the Trump campaign
here's what the indictment says quote
some defendants posing as US persons and
without revealing the Russian
Association communicated with unwitting
individuals associated with the Trump
campaign and with other political
activists to seek to coordinate
political activities folks that's not
collusion collusion you actually have to
know who you're talking to if I I don't
understand the argument that this is
collusion if I were to call up the Trump
campaign and say I wanted to a rally for
you in Texas and they say sounds great
let's do a rally in Texas and I'm not
Russian then it's not collusion if I am
Russian and I say let's go to a rally in
Texas and they don't know that I'm a
Russian agent then how is it collusion
it's only collusion if they know they're
forwarding the agenda of the of the
Kremlin if the Kremlin's agenda is that
is the Trump victory
that's not Trump's fault Trump's victory
is his own agenda the logic that you did
something and it happens to be
coincident with something the Russians
wanted not that you coordinated with
Russia and that's collusion still that
logic does not hold so what exactly did
all of these organizations do they
created quote certain fictitious u.s.
personas into leaders of public opinion
in the United States like what they
created the ematic group pages including
black Davis secured borders an army of
Jesus and they created Twitter accounts
like 10 GOP which ended up with more
than a hundred thousand followers by the
way that's the extent of what they did
that they created one Twitter account
that was successful and 100,000
followers you know many people have
accounts of 100,000 followers a lot you
know many people have accounts with over
a million followers not all that many
about 1.2 million followers right now if
the Russians really wanted to pour
resources into Twitter you'd figure they
would get one account that was really
really influential 100,000 followers
it's not all that influential so who did
they support quote they engaged in
operations primarily intended to
communicate derogatory information about
Hillary Clinton to denigrate other
candidates such as Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio and to support Bernie Sanders and
then candidate Donald Trump they
encouraged us minority groups not to
vote in the 2016 US presidential
election or to vote for a third party
u.s. presidential candidate so pushing
for Jill Stein and against Hillary
Clinton it sounds like they didn't like
Hillary very much and sounds like it was
more anti-hillary than pro Trump per se
but regardless the there is no evidence
of
actual Trump Russia collusion in these
indictments now could there be evidence
that appears later sure but we're still
waiting to see some rigged gates is a
member of the Trump campaign who's now
gonna be indicted looks like he's gonna
be indicted on charges having nothing to
do with Trump looks like it has to do
with corrupt activities with regard to
Ukraine and Paul Manafort
so so thus far we've had zero evidence
that the Trump campaign actively
colluded with the Russians the best that
they can do is say there was intense
clued that would be the meeting between
Donald Trump jr. and Russian lawyer
vessel Mnet's kya and Natalya vessel
Mnet's kya and the exchange that Trump
jr. had with a friend of his in Russia
who was saying the Russian government
wants to help out so intent to collude
is not a crime
actual collusion is probably not a crime
actually depending on how exactly it
went down but the the story we've been
told for over a years that the Russians
skewed the election to Hillary Clinton
and then the evidence they provide for
this is really scanty they putting up
memes on Facebook that have 15 shares
putting out dumb memes that have a
hundred shares on Twitter one Twitter
account that successful enough to have a
hundred thousand followers that's it so
Trump rightly comes out and starts
blasting away against the Democrats for
all of the Trump Russia stuff in an epic
tweet storm he says Russia started their
anti US campaign in in 2014 long before
I announced that I would run for
president the results of the election
were not impacted the Trump campaign did
nothing wrong no collusion fact check
true and then he says charges deals on a
big win written by Michael Goodwin of
the New York Post succinctly shows the
Russians had no impact on the election
results there was no collusion with the
Trump campaign she lost the
old-fashioned way by being a terrible
candidate case closed again fact-check
true this is deputy AG rod Rosenstein
stated at the press conference quote
there's no allegation in the indictment
that any american was a knowing
participant in this illegal activity
there's no allegation in the indictment
that the charged cons ought to altered
the outcome of the 2016 election yeah
Chuck true he continues in the funny how
the fake news media doesn't but doesn't
want to say that Russian group was it
was sorry was formed in 2014 long before
my run for president maybe they knew I
was gonna run even though I didn't know
it first of all a lot of the fake news
media did and the fact check false the
fake news media did actually point out
that this that this interference started
in 2014 and then he says I've seen all
of the Russian ads and I can say
definitively that swing the election was
not the main goal Rob Goldman vice
president of Facebook ads fact check
true so that all of this is true this is
very sad and now here's where he goes
off the rails here's where Trump cannot
help but be Trump and it's not good many
tweets quote very sad the FBI missed all
of the many signals sent out by the
Florida school shooter this is not
acceptable they're spending too much
time trying to prove Russian collusion
with the Trump campaign
there is no collusion get back to the
basics and make us all proud
this is stupid this is counterproductive
there is this is very dumb that last
comment there the FBI agents responsible
for stopping the school shooting we're
not the FBI agents who are investigating
Trump brush collusion that is a very
very stupid comment it's it's a comment
that devan's linking those two issues is
really gross and nasty and vulgar and
Trump never should have done it they
said quote I never said Russia did not
meddle in the election I said it may be
Russia or China or another country or
group or maybe a 400-pound genius
sitting in bed and playing with his
computer the Russian hoax was that the
Trump campaign colluded with Russia it
never did well that's really not true
either the president said over and over
and over that he doesn't really believe
that Russia meddled in the election he
said that Vladimir Putin keeps telling
him and he sees no reason not to believe
him that Russia didn't meddle in the
election he's expressed his doubts about
Russian meddling a thousand times but
with all of this said you know the
president can't help himself he gets on
Twitter he says silly things it's what
he does for a living aside from being
president but with all of that said
really this the the the basic notion
promoted by the Trump by the Trump
Mueller investigation the new and the
new allegations put out by the Muller
investigation it basically suggests that
Trump is not wrong here there's there's
never been a lot of strong evidence of
collusion between the Trump campaign in
the Russians and the media that keep
trying to push this story are gonna have
some real trouble if they continue to
push this story the Trump can be as dumb
as you wants on Twitter and he will but
that has nothing to do with the
underlying accusation made by the media
which is that Hillary Clinton didn't
lose the election the Russians wanted
for Trump there is no evidence of that
whatsoever any suggestions the contrary
is evidence free okay so in just a
second we're going to get to we're going
to get to sports and politics because I
need to play for you the worst rendition
of the national anthem in human history
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daily wire calm and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire calm when you do you get
the rest of
show live get the rest of the end room
Clavin shall live to get the rest of the
Michael Noel's show live you also get to
be part of our mailbag on Fridays you
get all sorts of goodies behind the
paywall and you will get to do all of
those things plus you get the annual
subscription the annual subscription it
allows you get all of those things Plus
this the very greatest and beverage
vessels right here the leftist years how
to quote about how great is it it has
the power of invisibility that's how
great it is it has its own cloaking
device it was produced in Wakanda it was
made from vibranium and it is
spectacular it is just that good so you
can check that out with a $99 annual
subscription fee thanks to just for
forgetting the cup really appreciate
that and right under the bus goes just
and we will and and you will be able to
enjoy all the glories of our leftist
here's hot and cold tumbler when you get
the annual subscription also if you just
wanna listen later to the rest of the
show go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube Google Play stitcher any of
those
Apple podcasts they all have the podcast
we are one of the largest podcasts in
the United States and we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the United States
so I do want to talk sports and politics
but in order for me to lead this off I
do have to discuss the worst national
anthem in the history of national
anthems this of course was from Fergie
who gave the national anthem a black guy
get it get it she gave it a black guy
Fergie yeah fer gie as i make the joke
again in case you missed it the first
time because it's so good fer gie LIC i
OMG WTF
here it is Fergie singing the worst
national anthem of all time watch the
reactions of the NBA players who are
listening to her Nealon would have done
less dishonor to the anthem than the way
that Fergie sang this national anthem
it's just horrifying
I'm never gonna cut it man I'm just
gonna let it play it's so good in the
world like what is going on man
[Music]
everybody's trying so hard not to laugh
at this lady them trying to LeBron
trying to hold in the laughs he's really
trying hard there it comes to a point in
this clap where the entire the entire
crowd actually starts laughing we have
to wait at least I'll get draymond
greens reaction oh no and she's a
terrible singer tear okay watch Trayvon
here is the best wait till they get to
draymond Green it's so good
[Music]
so terrible candles it in Jimmy and I
are on the same side here what the hell
is this oh so great okay
everybody's laughing now they can't hold
it in oh the capper is so good
[Music]
[Applause]
I think we can all come together around
Fergie is awful oh my goodness that is
just hot garbage Roseanne Barr finally
gets off the schnide because of Fergie
Wow Wow Carl Lewis off the schnide if
you know if you haven't seen them sing
the anthem by the way go to you who've
been looking up pretty spectacular yeah
I'm about this how about we just sing
the national anthem like it was supposed
to be sung as opposed to Marilyn Monroe
singing happy birthday to JFK while
having sex with him how about we don't
do that with the national anthem because
that was not good Wow okay now the
sports community has decided that it is
imperative that they all speak up on
politics very very important that if you
are good at basketball please speak up
I'm pilot so now it's fine you wanna
speak up in politics everyone in the
United States has the right and the
capacity to speak up on politics whether
we should respect your opinion is
another question lots of people have
very dumb opinions so among those who
have very stupid opinions is Adam rip on
so Adam rip on is a is an ice skater and
he says that quote I'm not like a gay
icon or America's gay sweetheart I'm
just America's Sweetheart and I'm just
an icon so Milo yeah innopolis coming
back as an ice skater there uh did this
this well he finished tenth like tenth
okay no finished tenth in the NFL last
year it was the Atlanta Falcons with the
ten and six record the Jacksonville
Jaguars also were ten and six this does
not make you an icon if you finished
tenth that does not make you an icon but
the media are so perverse that they
actually moved to give a damn rip on a
job as a commentator
after finishing tenth at the Olympics
can you name the person who finished
10th at the last Olympics you can't you
know why because they're not an icon
definitionally you finished 10th at the
Olympics are not an icon so NBC briefly
hired him to serve as a correspondent
for the rest of the 2018 games in
Pyeongchang South Korea he's one of the
first openly gay athletes to compete at
the Olympics and he won a bronze medal
for a figure skating at some point I
guess will work for NBC as a
correspondent on TV digital and social
media the only reason they're even
talking about having him first of all
anyone who thinks that he's a gay icon
in figure skating um guys
we're Brian Boitano have you watched the
figure-skating coverage at all I haven't
but if you have then you've seen Tara
Lipinski and Johnny Weir hey Johnny Weir
is dressed like Lady Gaga every day
commenting and commentating on this I
mean that guy is ten times as gay as
Adam Ripon or at least if you're if
you're talking about gay stereotypes he
is stereotypically gay much more than
Adam rip on he is a gay he's a gay icon
okay Johnny Weir was much more of a gay
icon than Adam Ripon but Adam rip on
ripped on mic pens and therefore he is
therefore he's a gay icon now for some
odd reason the media wished to prop up
these cultural figures because they
think that the American people actually
listen to them the American people don't
listen to them other people who the
American people don't really care about
hearing from on politics is a general
rule LeBron James so LeBron James can
say whatever he wants on politics Laura
Ingraham when she said shut up and play
basketball
ell LeBron James can say whatever dumb
thing he wants that's his prerogative
but LeBron James responded to Laura
Ingraham and so now we're gonna have a
LeBron James Laura Ingraham fight for no
apparent reason which is just awesome
for the culture here's LeBron oh
definitely not
shut up and dribble I would definitely
not do that I mean too much to to
society I mean too much to the youth I
mean too much to the to so many kids
that feel like they don't have a they
don't have a way out and they need
someone to help lead them out of the
situation they're in and that's why I
would not just shut up and dribble
because I mean too much to my two boys
here their best friend right here my
daughter that's at home my wife my
family and all these other kids that
look up to me for inspiration
okay that's his prerogative that's his
prerogative and it is worth pointing out
people were saying this is a race thing
hey joy Reid came out and she said that
it's just that Laura Ingraham wanted to
slam a black guy that's why the Laura
Ingraham did this yeah this is ignorance
here's where I read had to say extent to
which Fox News has decided that the the
grist for the ratings mill is black
people right black NFL players black NBA
players I mean you had eminem make a
music video attacking Donald Trump
that's not interesting to them right the
grist is always black and brown people
because they know what it sells and yet
you have Laura Ingraham taking such
umbrage and saying
oh how dare you say my my words were
racist um her words weren't racist she
wrote an entire book it was a New York
Times bestseller called shut up and sing
about the Dixie Chicks the Dixie Chicks
last I checked are the whitest people on
planet Earth and she wrote an entire
book about how people who are in the
music business should shut up and sing
in the her home has been Laura schtick
for a very very long time it let's let's
at least be honest about the critiques
that were making of people if you think
that Laura Ingraham shouldn't have said
the LeBron James who shut up and rebel
because you think that everyone has a
right to speak that's fine but if you
want to say that that's a racist thing
Laura Ingraham has been saying this
about every celebrity that she can find
for the last 15 to 20 years I know I was
there but joy Reed wants to say it's a
racial thing also the idea that Fox News
is is somehow ignoring the Eminem music
video they covered the me time and I
mean I was on Fox and Friends I think
the morning they covered it they've
covered the M in a music video over and
over and over again then they covered
the Snoop Dogg music video one of the
reasons that they keep covering
quote/unquote black folks in it in in
athletics is because it's a lot of black
folks in athletics who are becoming very
political these days because they think
that Trump is racially biased and they
think Trump's a racist and all the rest
of it the vast majority of players who
are kneeling for the anthem in the NFL
were black the vast majorities and
players and in the in the NBA who are
wearing black lives matters t-shirts
were black because the vast majority of
players in the NBA are black it's not
that Fox News is this this attempt to
graft racial issues onto what are really
political issues I don't like very much
another note about LeBron LeBron says
I'm too important to people not to speak
up but that may be true there are a lot
of people who find LeBron James very
important and they want to hear from him
that may be true in the same way that it
was true for Muhammad Ali I don't like
making sports figures into coach into
political figures because I don't think
they know very much about politics as a
general rule the mistake that Laura
Ingraham made here was suggesting if she
made a mistake her it was suggesting
that innately LeBron James is not
capable of talking about politics
because he's a basketball player as
opposed to he doesn't know what he's
talking about therefore we shouldn't pay
any attention and the problem isn't
LeBron speaking out the problem is a
society that takes celebrities seriously
on politics how do I know that our
society takes celebrities seriously on
politics the President of the United
States is Donald J Trump okay yes we
take our power our celebrity seriously
on politics it's store on the right and
it's true on the left
you can't critique LeBron for speaking
out on politics if you were willing to
vote for a Kid Rock in the US Senate
race in Michigan
you can't talk about how you don't like
celebrities talking about politics if
you are excited every time Clint
Eastwood makes a political statement if
he it doesn't work from one side and not
for the other and on the left you can't
whine about Donald Trump is a celebrity
what does he know about politics if
every time a celebrity comes forward
like Lena Dunham whining about abortion
you take her super seriously because she
writes a terrible show on HBO either
either we're gonna have to judge people
based on their expertise or we're gonna
have this whole other ancillary set of
gauges that we use for determining
legitimacy how close were they to a
stage so we'll use sympathy how close
were they to a situation that affected
them or we'll use celebrity as a marker
of decency and genius or we could say
well does this person know anything
about what they're talking about and if
the answer is no then maybe we shouldn't
as a people take them particularly
seriously maybe Adam rip ons take on
politics is not particularly relevant
because anna pun doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about he went on
national television and suggested that
the vice president of the United States
is for gay conversion therapy which is
factually false
maybe we shouldn't offer him a slot on
ice skating coverage so he can do his
pull up his politicking at NBC by the
way they withdrew the offer apparently
after there was some blowback the reason
that people are up in arms about sports
and politics is because there's been a
whole set of media elites who have
decided that sports figures and cultural
figures have something deep to say and
you see it every time there's one of
these controversies and a bunch of
people come out and say where's Taylor
Swift on this issue where's Taylor Swift
been on me - where's Taylor Swift pin on
the hats who cares what Taylor
Swift has been on any of this she writes
papí teen beat songs who cares why does
it matter where she is on this why would
I possibly care what a boxer has to say
about this stuff unless the boxers
actually spent some time learning about
the political issues at issue there are
boxers by the way who spend time on
politics I mean is it Vladimir Klitschko
the the heavyweight or his brother who
is very involved in Ukrainian politics
but the mark of expertise should not be
how many cameras are on you on an
ancillary thing the mark of expertise
should be whether you actually know what
the hell you're talking about Jennifer
Lawrence by the way says she's taking
off time from acting - to change the to
save our democracy so she apparently
thinks The Hunger Games is a real thing
she's gonna go get her bow and arrow and
run out there if the previews for red
Sparrow were any indicator then
think we've all been blessed by her
decision but Jennifer Lawrence why are
we paying attention to her on politics
who cares what Jennifer Lawrence has to
say on politics the answer is no one
should because she doesn't know what
she's talking about but we all will
because celebrity now dominates the
roost okay time for some things I like
some things I hate and then we will get
to a federalist paper so things I like
we could really do a thing I like and a
thing I hate together for Black Panther
because it is it is really some of both
so I saw Black Panther over the weekend
it is a very good Marvel movie I am NOT
a Marvel fan I am a DC / Marvel guy I I
have to analyze it on on two levels the
the Black Panther it film so one is the
movie level is it a good movie the
answer is yes I think it's a good movie
I think it's a well-made movie I think
it's compelling I found the characters
interesting I thought the story moved
yeah I I liked the movie I thought that
was better than most of the Marvel
movies that I've seen recently I think
it probably fall I said top three and
you probably fall top five for me now in
terms of the Marvel films I think what
do they made 17 of them now I mean a
bunch of them the my top 5 Marvel films
this would be on there I really like to
throw Ragnarok it didn't take itself too
seriously that would be on there ant-man
would be on there I know them I'm in the
minority believing this ant-man would be
on there I really like dr. strange
without dr. strange yeah they have a
weird Marvel list of movies that I like
and they tend to be lighter Black
Panther is heavier and I think that it's
pretty good for that so it's well made
the acting across the board is really
good except for Forest Whitaker
bizarrely who plays the same character
in every film now so Forest Whitaker has
basically become the guy he played in
rogue one and he's like that in every
single science fiction film he's kind of
like Jeff Goldblum that way when you
cast Forest Whitaker you know you're
getting Forest Whitaker you're not gonna
get really a performance but everybody
else in the film is great Michael B
Jordan steals the film as the villain
kill monger he's the best thing in it
but the performance is across the board
are quite good okay so that's level
number one is the film good that's what
so things I like I like that that's good
it's a good film so we can show a little
bit of preview and then I will explain
some things about the film that I did
not like
tell me something what do you know about
Kenda is the third world country
textiles Shepherds cool outfits or front
explores has searched though it called
it El Dorado
thank for it in South America
I'm the only one okay so the movies good
Andy Andy Serkis by the way is terrific
in the film and they should have him in
noir films or he's not CGI to the monkey
or something he's he's he's quite a good
actor and I really enjoyed him in the
film he plays I'm a crazy guy okay so we
have to end so I analyzed it as a film
very enjoyable very good movie
okay now the politics so before I go any
further I want to point something out I
did not politicize this film you
politicize this film media because you
guys who made this into a big issue I'm
gonna read you some of the headlines
from the New York Times these are the
headlines from the New York Times about
this film in the last two weeks alone
one Black Panther smashes box-office
records in Hollywood myths
I took seventh graders to see Black
Panther here's what they said
Black Panther and the revenge of black
nerds how Black Panther got it's
gorgeous Afrocentric era why Black
Panther is a defining moment for black
America Black Panther brings hope hype
and pride hey people last week we're
saying I was very upset that there is
this movie being made no I'm not I don't
care whether the movie is made it's a
good movie I enjoyed it what I care
about is that the media are treating
this as some sort of glorious moment
like this is a very very important
cultural moment it's not a very
important cultural moment I'm sorry it
isn't there been blockbusters with black
leads black comic book characters and
films including Nick Fury hit movies
primarily about black people for years
critically acclaimed movies about black
people for years in the last five years
I think 12 years of slave and moonlight
both won both about black people so the
idea that the Americans are not willing
to go see a movie with primarily black
people like what are you talking about I
just don't see the evidence for any of
that and there's this this kind of
virtue signaling that's now going around
people saying they love the movie a
little more than they do because they
want to prove that they want to see a
movie with black people in liked it I
think that's really dumb the movies good
is it is it Citizen Kane no it's not
Citizen Kane is it a very good Marvel
movie sure okay the politics didn't go
beyond that though so it's not just it's
important for black kids to see a black
superhero which I find a dubious measure
I don't think it's important for white
kids to see a white superhero I think
it's fine for white kids to see a black
superhero like Black Panther I think
it's fine for black kids to see a white
superhero I don't care it makes no
difference to me but there's something
beyond that so Carvel Wallace wrote this
in the in the New York Times quote no
one knows colonization better than the
car
and black folks wasted no time in
recolonizing Wakanda no genocide or
takeover of land was required
what Kansai is ours now we do with it as
we please and then he said also in this
article that there's a video posted to
Twitter in December which has since gone
viral three young men seen fawning over
the Black Panther Post heard a movie
theater one jokingly embraces the poster
well another asks rhetorically this is
what white people get to feel like all
the time there's laughter before someone
says is those delivering the punchline
to the most painful joke ever told I
would love this country to accept
nobody's ever gone to see a Captain
America movie and said wow look a movie
with a white hero
I'm so excited he's white nobody does
that in America that's not a thing and
they certainly don't go to a movie and
say wow look a movie with all white
people and all the black people are bad
because that would be a racist movie
that would be Birth of a Nation that's
bad I took no this is not okay so what
are the politics that are actually the
movie I didn't politicize it you pull it
aside sister now I have to break down
the politics sorry I have to do that
shouldn't ruin your experience in the
film it's a good film okay so here's
what's good Martin Luther King defeats
Malcolm X so there are two main
characters in the film one is two Chawla
who is a stolid Chadwick Boseman
and one in he's sort of plays the MLK
figure he's taking over from Wakanda so
I have to explain the plot of the film
so spoilers ahead okay if you don't want
to hear the spoilers tune out now here
are the spoilers so there's a fictional
Kingdom it does not exist because the
entire none of this exists right it's
Marvel Universe but we're gonna pretend
that it does exist for purposes of this
conversation because when you analyze
the politics of a film and the messages
that are being promoted by the film you
have to take it on its own terms so here
is the so here's what's going on there
is a country called Wakanda what Konza
was hit with a meteorite that is filled
with vibranium vibranium is basically
unobtainium it is the greatest metal
that has ever been created it can heal
spinal wounds
it can give you visions of your
forefathers it can do anything vibranium
it's just unbelievably cool crap and it
can turn your entire civilization
apparently so long as there are no white
people in your civilization it can turn
your entire civilization into a fully
westernized fully liberal place with gay
rights and women running the military
and women running all the science
weren't running all the science
institutions
and all this Auto Tech cultural
influences don't matter all that matters
in this universe is that a big meteorite
landed right here and that there were no
white people to ruin it that was pretty
much the premise of Wakanda and then
what kind of hides from everybody but
they still have the greatest country
ever without any trade
they have this metal but the metal
magically can grow things and it can it
can make everything super cool it can be
isolationist you can have a complete
complete state with no outside
interference at all now pause in real
life this doesn't work out for anyone
Japan was the closest thing to this
America basically opened Japan with a
couple of gunboats hey China was like
this in the 1860s the United States sent
a couple of gunboats into China during
the Boxer Rebellion and basically took
over the earth during the opium wars and
basically took over large swaths of
China and opened it to trade so this is
not accurate okay when you cut yourself
off from the outside world it typically
makes you weaker not stronger but put
that aside hey so what Conda is
fantastic it's the greatest place ever
but what kind that didn't help out black
people around the world when black
people were suffering at the hands of
white people so the king of Wakanda
before it's a travel was to Chaka it's
his dad to Chaka had a brother
his brother was sent as a spy to Oakland
why would you send a spy to Oakland
no one knows okay know what's in Oakland
were you trying to get the Raiders
playbook there's nothing going on in
Oakland that needs spying on innocent a
spy he spit him to Washington DC right
to the Russians spend time sending their
spies to help Trump in Oakland no okay
so that's stupid but they send they sent
him to Oakland he sent his brother to
Oakland and his brother in Oakland then
turns into basically like a black
panther like an actual militant guy who
says that America he gives a whole
speech about how America is filled with
discrimination and how black people in
America are essentially living in
poverty because the white people have
flooded their neighborhoods with drugs
and over-policing
there's an actual black lives matter
speech in the middle of the film okay
the the then he tries to smuggle some
vibranium out to all of these Black
Panthers type groups and to chop guy has
to kill him
so to track that kills brother the
brother had a son the brother son is
Michael B Jordan who grows up to be kill
monger his entire agenda is what kinda
has all of this awesome vibranium why
don't we help out oppress people's
around the world overthrow their
colonialist masters okay that's the
premise of the film and that's the
conflict - ciao - ciao low winds and
kill mongrel losses so MLK defeats
defeats commander that's good right em
okay is program is better than Malcolm
X's program militants and separatism is
not better than integration and and the
belief that life should get better for
everybody
however the film's real message is that
kill monger is right and that's that
it's impossible to watch the film and
not feel some
they foretell maunder because of the way
the script is written there that's for a
couple of reasons one Lacan is
incredible in this film the United
States is garbage for black people
terrible place to live for black people
now again break2 real-life America is
the best place on earth for black people
there is no better place on planet Earth
for black people as a group of human
beings just like there is no better
place for women or jews or anyplace else
on planet earth for anyone than the
United States just a fact Hey measure it
in terms of income measure it in terms
of lifestyle however you want to do it
America is a fantastic place for black
people that does not justify colonialism
it does not justify slavery evil things
are evil but that is not the same thing
as saying that black people in the
United States right now are somehow
under the boot of the white supremacist
institution which is which is sort of
the premise of the film so the United
States and the film's garbage and
Wakanda is great that being the case
kill mongers actually right he's
suggesting that black people in the
United States are oppressed and that the
system in the United States is
legitimate because of colonialism and
slavery and therefore you have to
overthrow that with violence that seems
like not the worst logic and that
doesn't seem completely wrong now the
reason it's wrong in real life is
because colonization can be wrong and
unjustifiable and so can slavery but the
suggestion that the province of
modern-day Africa lie and colonization
and slavery as opposed to a lot of
internal problems that have existed for
centuries in many places around the
world including in Africa and that those
problems continue today that's too
simplistic okay that's too simplistic to
blame that on colonization and slavery
because that's that's silly okay that's
it so that's that's but the message is
the the wrong message here which the
kill monger is basically correct there
are a couple of minds in here that
underscore this one of the people in the
film who sort of the the cue figure
isn't James Bond cue one of the people
in the film is a is the sister of
T'Challa and for no reason at all just
calls a white boy white guy white boy
she calls the she calls Bilbo Baggins
white boy for no reason and then she
also says she calls him colonizer like
literally for no reason he walks out of
bed and she goes don't don't surprise me
like that colonizer it's like really
yeah you just drop that in the middle of
a film and it's totally cool cuz all
white people are colonizers now by the
way the united states the least
colonizing power in the history of great
powers okay so that some of the stuff
that I just like there's also some rips
against the US military the solution at
the end of the film is apparently not
militants but spending lots of money in
the interstate
it's a chili decides that he's gonna
that he's gonna buy up the portion of
Oakland where his where his cousin grew
up and and he's gonna spend a lot of
money on stem technologies or somesuch
we've tried that it has not been a giant
success the problem inside a lot of
communities failing communities in the
United States white black and green is
lack of fathers crime rates that are too
high
lack of social institutions not lack of
monetary investment we spent lots of
money on the war on poverty it has not
been particularly effective there's some
mixed messaging on walls
we learned that walls are bad there's
what they actually one of the characters
actually say I think it's Charlie says
we don't need to build walls we need to
build bridges except for the fact that
the entire what Kahn's in Empire is
built because of a wall and that two of
the four people who are in Wakanda have
tried to destroy what Conda so that's
not a really great immigration program
apparently but not every listen not
everything is all the messages are bad
it says that women can be great at
science which is fine it says that what
it's good I mean great it says that race
is not an obstacles to success which is
true and good I hope people take away
the good messages and not the bad but
there's the full breakdown of that you
know we're gonna we're out of time here
so we're gonna have to do our federalist
paper tomorrow so we'll save our
federalist paper for tomorrow we do that
every week but you'll just have to come
back here tomorrow for that i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing